Hey, what's going on it's Bill Burr.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday. Monday
morning podcast said, Huh?
[inaudible]
just checking in on you.
Just checking in on your fucking
red line in the goddamn levels.
Here you bring this down here. Ah, Jesus.
I got shit to do today,
so let's fucking get right to it.
Yeah.
Do you see these goddamn things?
Fuck it by him.
I found that youtube clip the other day
member on the fat kid. We'll review food.
That was my favorite one. Fat Kid
reviews, girl scout cookies. He goes,
sees a girl scout mint chocolate
chip cookies and I fucking love them.
Like me. Sits there and he ate some looks
up in the air and then he goes up some.
You see somebody selling these
goddamn things, fucking buy them.
It's one of the greatest
food reviews ever.
I totally believed him and I want
to girl scout cookies. But anyways,
I'm not here to talk about this.
I'm not in it. Talk about that.
I'm here as a casual fucking
fan of the NBA. Meaning,
I've probably watched seven whole
games in the last seven fucking years.
And I watched the second half of
last night's Cleveland Cavaliers,
first the fucking Golden State Warriors,
um,
in a bar with the sound out.
Now here comes my analogy,
my favorite fucking moment
of last night and this thing,
I don't have a dog in the fight.
I'd love to see Lebron win a
championship for Cleveland. And, um,
I always like the golden state warriors
because they, they stunk, you know,
and their fans fucking hung in there.
And I liked their floor and all of that
shit in that old piece of Shit stadium
they play.
And I went to a game there.
I went to a game there
about fucking 10 years ago,
and there was like nobody there. And
they had these sickest fucking live band.
They're the old plane. Herbie Hancock.
What does that sound? Wild AOD or what?
Barrow do Ruby.
Wow.
Deep that did do that
fucking sickest shit ever, right? It
was way better than mine. I just did
the fuck was the name of that song?
I got that on my fucking phone somewhere.
Oh, Jesus. Uh, you know, and I'll
play it for you here in a second.
Maybe you guys understand what this one
is. Herbie Hancock. It wasn't watermelon,
man.
What the fuck was it called?
Headhunter her be head cock.
I'm going to hit pause while I look
this up so I don't torture you here.
All right, good. I got, they were playing.
They were playing Herbie
Hancock Chameleon. I met a
professional basketball game.
There's nobody there. There's fucking live
band is crushing this song right here.
Come on,
play it for fuck sakes.
Me. Just look around like, just fucking
game sucks. Listen to this band though.
The killing it.
Harvey Mason.
All right. Alright.
Black people all start moving around.
White people start getting uncomfortable
and the guitar player comes in.
Maybe it comes in in the next [inaudible]
very comfortable.
I felt like it was in a fucking
movie, so I was like, you know what?
I love this franchise. You know
what this is? This is if you shot,
this is what you should be
doing. And saying, listen man,
we're only going to
win eight games a year.
Let's fucking get a killer band to come
in there and people can leave to have a
good time. It was a fucking party and
they lost by like fucking 30. So anyways,
I got, I don't have a dog in this
fight and I watched this game.
MMM.
I watched this game with the fucking
sound on that was Herbie Hancock Chameleon
by the way,
before you try to shit Zammit point your
phone at your fucking dashboard while
you're driving down the street.
Killing a fucking mother is six. Um,
I have to tell you this over the last
couple of games that I've watched,
like the NBA has fucking changed so much
the way Steph curry just runs around
the court. Like it's his,
like the whole thing is his,
it's his fucking showcase when he was
sitting on the bench and that dude hits
the three pointer and he did
that little jazz hand thing.
Yeah.
Whatever
the fuck he was doing,
you know,
dribbles out the game and
then looks at the crowd, goes
[inaudible] fucking screaming.
I'm just looking at him. Okay,
now I know this guy could fucking
body slammed me. I'm just a comedian,
but I'm talking about NBA player,
Nba play at this fucking guy is,
he's built like an honor roll student.
All right?
And I know he can shoot the fucking lights
out from behind the three point line.
Fine. You know, you do the
best she can back there,
but you let that little mother fucker
just glide down the Goddamn Lane like
clear, clearer path to
today's NBA. Don't touch him.
Don't fucking touch him.
That guy needs to get his head taken off.
Get one of those fucking giant white
dudes from fucking eastern Europe.
Some Transylvania guy. Get him
out there. He's got six files.
Just, you know, you know what
would happen? He'd do fucking
one. They'd be like, Ooh,
32 channel with e trade or
whatever the fuck they call it.
Was that a hard foul? Was he trying
to hurt his feelings with that foul?
Oh, let's go over and look at the
tape. What do you think was, was,
was his face snarl too much when
he did that? Uh, we can have that.
Get him out of the game.
You know,
it's still worth it to fucking do it
because I can see it back in the day.
You know the Rick,
my horns that John Sally's all
at all of these fucking guy,
John Sally passed away unfortunately.
But all of those fucking old school NBA
guys gotta be this fucking kid and just
be sitting there going like, yeah dad,
that that wouldn't happen. Rightfully
that guy would have got
his fucking head taken off.
Do you know if you watch highlights of
Jordan all you young millennial fucking
Yolo people out there. If you fucking
watch him, it's like he's skinny,
he's skinny,
and then all of a sudden he's filled out.
That was because the Pistons beat the
shit out of them. EPFL like fucking two,
three years in a row in the playoffs.
He finally had enough
guy had to go to the gym because the
NBA reps weren't protecting them.
They keep come down there.
They'd fucking do remember one time
fucking bill and beer, one of the,
it's always like,
I'll,
Sam is sin without skates out there who
hilariously in the 30 for 30 used to be
like, we used to like to try and
get in people's heads. It's like,
like he was playing this high level
fucking mind game. It's like, no dude,
you were just out there waiting for
people to leave their feet and you'd take
their fucking legs out.
How'd you come up with that?
It's your major in Calculus.
Um,
so I remember one time he was
hacking the Celtics so fucking bad.
Robert Parish finally couldn't take it.
And the players go on up the court and
he just fucking gave him two, four.
I'm smashes over their head.
He chopped them down like a fucking,
do you ever see like when a guy who does
not to chop down a tree chops down to
train,
it falls into his house?
That's the way he was hacking
away at Lam beer and land beer.
Just put both his hands
up like, oh, you know,
like George Michael when he was with
wham and he just fucking went down.
All right. He gave him to fucking ruin
your friends. Right. And he went down,
the refs didn't see it.
It was like wrestling.
And then when they back they went back
and looked at the tape. You're like, yeah,
well, you know, we should've called
the fall and there was no fines.
There was no objections, there
was no nothing. He just, you know,
live by the sword, die by the sword.
Um, there was so many of those.
I just was thinking another
one that I saw, they just,
it just nowadays you just
covered is out there just fucking
gliding around.
He's built like a muppet.
I just don't understand in this
day and age how that has happened.
And the only thing that I can come up
with is that the leagues is so fucking
guilty that not guilty greedy
is that they realize that,
you know, um, that offense
sells tickets to the casual fan.
You know what I mean? Like, let's
take the most boring game ever.
And I'm not talking about horseshoes.
I'm not talking about shuffleboard.
I'm not talking about darts.
I of course am talking about soccer.
Okay?
Which the entire world has embraced except
for us and when you really look at it,
that's probably why we're number one.
You know what I mean?
The rest of the world is too stupid to
realize how boring that fucking game is
despite the fact that it's so fucking
boring that even their fans have to have
campfires singalongs as they
wait for something to happen.
I want some added with Agn Hayes
all Righ, right? Just sitting there,
they're fucking scarves and shit.
This is the thing about,
Oh man, I'm going to get
some fucking emails in this.
This is the thing about fucking soccer,
right?
If they just let the forwards run
past the final line of defense,
like in any other competitive
fucking game where it's like, hey,
I'm faster than you.
I understand like offsides to a point,
but it's got to be a,
just a line like in hockey and then
after that, if I'm faster than you,
if I can see the play developing
before you do, I get by you.
I don't have to fucking wait for you.
If they would just adjust that and you'd
start to have some fucking 10 to eight
games,
I'm telling you that game would blow up.
Okay.
Blow up here in the United States we
would sit down and fucking watch it.
You know why?
Because we don't understand the game,
you know what I mean?
If I was watching cricket right,
I guess they score a lot
in that fucking thing.
That's a good one to just
sit around and booze with,
but any fucking game then I'm not into,
if somebody is crushing it and everybody's
flipping out, I'm going to be like,
what's going on? I'm going to actually
going to sit there and watch it.
Like nobody, like when I walked
by, you know in soccer is on,
I don't even look at it,
but if I hit this guy go,
he's doing that. I stopped
and I watch, you know,
and I read all the fucking advertising's
all over there fucking uniforms.
I got to tell you,
the premier league has the worst fucking
uniforms I've ever seen in my life.
You can't figure out who to fuck anybody.
It doesn't say man United,
it doesn't say Liverpool.
It just says Exxon and fucking
Joey's fish and chips fucking banks.
I heard they're going to do
that in the NBA. But anyways,
I think that that's what
happened to the game. And I know,
I don't know what the
fuck I'm talking about.
I'm too fucking busy to pay attention.
And at the end of the day I never
really excelled in sports anyway.
So who better to break down?
What's wrong with the fucking NBA than
some stuttering fucking prick like me? Um,
I think you got an entire generation
of people that grew up playing Madden
football and all of this shit and
everybody was the globe trotters.
And now that just doing like the
real version of it. All right.
I love Steph Curry. He's the greatest
shoot I've ever seen in my life.
But watching him just glide down
the fucking lane is ridiculous,
which is why last night after
the fucking whistle blows,
he just decides like, Oh,
I'm just gonna fucking yell.
I'm going to take a little lay up here,
you know right next to Lebron James,
and I loved that Lebron blocked it and
looked at him like, fuck Outta here.
That's what they need to do.
All right,
you're not going to beat these fucking
guys play in their Goddamn game trying to
outshoot fucking three pointers or
whatever the fuck it is they're doing.
Granted, I watched it with the
sound down in the second half. Um,
they need to fucking, they got
it. They got you. I'm telling you,
they got to give him the right Dave for
it. That's what they got to do. Okay.
That's what you do. If the other team is
faster, the other team fucking you get,
you have to play physical. I'm not saying
play dirty Pittsburgh Penguin fans.
I'm not saying you hire a fucking knee
breaker and and the career of the best
player on the other team.
I'm not saying that.
All I'm saying is when the
guy comes down the leg,
your whole team should be
yelling, Clara path. You know,
when this guy looks like he's in
the fucking globe trotters. Um,
now, now that I'm done with
that, a little fucking Soliloquy,
most of that was based in what
happens is you get older, you know,
and you start realizing
your own mortality.
And there's a couple of panic
thoughts that you have is, you know,
the world is churches. Oh, I'm
gonna die and it's gonna keep going.
Part of it was that, that the game
has changed. You know what I mean?
I am kind of the old man going,
why can't they have short
shorts again and close lines.
It's amazing. Somebody balls didn't
come out like during that Rambus play.
It's unbelievable that his
junk didn't come out the side.
He fucking literally did. Like,
you know, like, uh, he did,
he was doing like a Thomas
flair in the air. And
Dude, I actually retweeted the
other day. It was in a game.
Jack [inaudible] elbows, Kareem Abdul
Jabbar in the fucking like right in,
right in the right inhale,
solar plexus used to say in wrestling
and cream had to like fucking just run it
off like fuck. So whatever happened
on the play where the sea, uh,
the sonics hit the shot or not, they're
going back up to court or whatever. No,
they didn't cause what's his face?
Sigma was still setting up.
Corinne walked back into the play and
just got a little in front of Jack Sigma
turned around and punched him right
in the face. It's sick my head,
that great hair, you know, that hair
that like moves around if he get hit,
you know,
he had whip lash hair,
the white version of it where
Thomas Hitman Hearns had
the black version when he
fought, uh, when he
fought. Um, Marvin Hagler,
you know, if a black guy
who's going to get punched in,
they hadn't a boxing match,
you want them to have a Jerry curl
because it just adds to it when all that
liquid just shoots off his fucking head.
And Jack Sigma had the white version
of it where he had basically a Beatles
haircut.
So it just enhances,
you really get to see like how much
you know, whiplash somebodies enduring.
Um, all right. There we go.
That's just the end of it. I, I,
you know what it is selfishly
I want to see seven games. Um,
and uh, I would like to see, all
right, one teams, a finessed team,
the other teams of physical team,
I don't want to say it, he 30 play,
but I don't see one team,
you know,
putting on their Tutus and trying to
out fucking spin the other team. Right.
Isn't that what I'm saying there and Nino,
sorry,
I'm trying to plow my
way through this podcast.
So they got to go a do a table read there.
You want to join the podcast?
You just coming in to say hello.
I just called Tuesday as a day.
Not Today.
I got one more day and I'm 30,
but tomorrow it's your birthday.
Oh yeah. Where are you taking me?
Chucky cheese.
I get to work to come here.
I do. I feel about it.
How do you feel about your birthday?
Um, this is a weird one. Why?
Because usually at my advanced age,
I start going like, Oh
God, and I was this number.
Now I'm that number, right? This one.
I, I don't, I've just sort of, uh,
you know, somewhere when I went
during my year of being 47,
I realized it's over
what's over my sex appeal.
My, uh, my dream of being one of people
magazine's 50 most beautiful people.
Uh, yeah, that one might
be a little batteries,
but his sex appeal I think
is getting strong. Oh, Jesus.
Everybody gets a ribbon nowadays.
Um,
so I just have settled into a,
I went and I got glasses the other day.
Yes, you did. Cleo. Get out of
there. That was a grape nuts.
Those are not for you.
Go Fat. She's getting,
she's not that fast. She's fat. You're
fat and you're not going to get a date.
No one's going to love. You
know, I've been so busy,
I've been able to work.
Grab a microphone to,
cause you're gonna drive
people nuts off off the thing.
Go get a court people not to drive.
You can drive me nuts cause a
microphone in the closet. Huh?
I feel like the narrow and knock and I'm
good fellas now keep going right down
there. Yeah, it was scaring me,
Karen. Um, no, this one
I'm, I'm just now like,
I'm Kinda like, all right,
I'm old now. It's all about,
and because I had psychiatric,
uh,
Erica,
um,
I realize now that all I give a shit is
that if I just can sit down and not have
pain, I'll be fine. And I want to thank
everybody that have given me all their,
their, you know, remedies and
all of that stuff. You know,
it's funny. It's, yeah,
it's funny as hell how they fucking
do it where it's done with love,
but in a Twitter way like,
hey fuck it.
Just if you have Sayada just do this,
get over and get on one of those foam
rollers and roll out your para us.
And it's like, I did that. I did
that. I've done all of that shit.
I actually went to the chiropractor
again yesterday and he said that the
swelling on my spine has
gone down tremendously.
I am now on the next level of healing.
Well now I don't have pain.
I just feel like, uh, it's a little
tingly sometimes my foot falls asleep.
I've been doing these stretches,
body mind at work got in this,
you know like do of those things
where you hang upside down. Yeah.
He got one that's actually
not legal in this country. Um,
but do they sell it in Canada,
Canada and you just basically, uh,
you're more hanging from like your
waist as opposed to your ankle.
Dad was talking about,
my dad was talking about the one
where you hang from your ankles. Yeah.
And what my chiropractor was
saying was that that one,
it puts stress on your joints cause
you got your whole body weight,
puts like your ankles,
your knees and your hips because your
whole body weight with this other one
loves that thing though.
Yeah. I don't know.
A lot of people love
it for whatever reason,
but I've been using the other one
and that one would be like, uh,
say like you were at the zoo and you're
at the gorilla and closure and you want
to bend over and look for the dime. You
just fucking lost. This is a very timely,
yeah, just imagine that
except you don't fall in,
I use the thing it'll fit adult
if an adult fell in there. Yeah.
What did they have shot at?
What?
The tranquilizer thinking that maybe
the adult could handle the fucking
thrashing that he was going to get.
I think that the adult would have had the
presence of mind to like slowly try to
back out of this situation as opposed
to a baby that's just kinda like sitting
there.
Can you give us an example of how you
would slowly back of a situation with the
gorilla? Alright. You Fall in
God, what would you say? Hey Man,
like easy, easy. Well, you know,
I'm terrified of primates.
Like they just freaked me out in general,
so I don't really know what I would
do because I just feel like, oh,
I know what I would do common like Dna
wise or something with a chimpanzee than
they do with a gorilla. Like
they, that freaks me out. I know,
I know exactly what I would
do. I don't like it. Actually,
I would curl up in the fetal position
and I would cover up my face so he
wouldn't rip it off and
I would just be like,
if I got to take some
gorilla fucking kidney shots,
I would much rather take the ASV comes
over and just fucking whales on me,
like from fucking ankle
to the side of my head.
I will take that before I will.
I will just stand there with my face
out waiting for you to rip it off.
Well I do they, yeah, I mean I feel
like that's probably the best way to go.
So they don't see you as like a threat
or something like you just sort of submit
to them or something? I don't know.
But then I don't want them to be like,
I'm sure this information is on the
Internet now. Like it's just so weird.
I don't know. They just,
they really freaked me out.
Remember when we went to Australia,
you know they're going to grab you by
your ankle and just drag you around like a
fucking, they did that little
kid. I haven't watched it.
Oh remember when we went to Australia
and I was telling you a video of it.
I don't want to watch that.
I did.
I did watch still one of the naked guy
that walked into the line and closure and
he's trying to kill himself.
Oh.
And the fucking is his neck is in
the guy in the fucking things naked.
I mean, I was talking about that on TV.
Oh my God. Yeah, it's a little, yeah,
it's like, go ahead, grab my neck,
but I still got a cup of my junk.
You still got to keep your boxes
on, right? No, but that's the thing.
The thing was just handled by his
neck and survive. Yeah. But cause I,
they must've just fed the fucking thing.
So it just had him around the neck.
It's in the guys,
literally,
he's got his arms around the things that
lions neck and then he's basically in
any wrapped his legs around his body.
He basically had it in the guard,
like a Jujitsu guard and the
fucking lion and around his throat,
but he wasn't shaking them or anything.
And everyone's like, you know, going,
Oh my God, Oh my God. And you
know, in whatever fucking language,
whatever country it was in their film and
the guy goes completely fucking naked.
And um,
yeah,
he obviously had like mental
issues because if you're
in sound mind and you kill
yourself, you just like jump
off something, right? Yeah.
You don't wander into a land on somebody's
know naked Volkswagen Passat. Wait,
but I wanted to say when we
went to Australia that time,
were you with me when I was in that
monkey exhibit or whatever and it looked
like planet of the apes
and it was freaking me out.
And then we went into that other little
side room and there was a monkey behind
the glass and everyone was looking at
it and taking pictures and he started
rocking back and forth and I was like,
that thing is about to freak out.
And then it threw itself up against the
glass and like screamed and yelled and
everyone was like all, then
the other chimp came in? Yes.
The campaign and like tried
to come and I did. Yeah,
we thought they were going to fight and
then they embraced each other and then
they like put their bags toward the
glass with one of them's arm around the
other. Like it's going to be okay. Like
we're going to get out of here some day.
Like it was so emotional and it
was so scary. I just, I can't,
I don't know. I can't deal with it. Like
that scene in the trailer for Tarzan,
the legend of Tarzan or the monkey comes
in and like see is the Tarzan in the
bassinet and then picks it up and
then leaves with it as just like,
I don't know. I don't
like that shit. Yeah,
I think it's really weird. I mean,
if that was in the wild, they would,
they would eat that baby and
they would actually leave it,
keep it alive as long as they could
because they enjoy the screaming cause it
fucking is that true that
they get off on it, man.
Two chimpanzees are fucking evil.
Gorilla is a chill.
Gorillas don't have anything to prove.
Champ champ. The short man's disease.
I feel like gorilla in our little more
chill and then he got those tweaks are
monkeys. Yeah, right.
The meth head ones. Yeah.
Those ones that throw their shit at you.
The chimpanzee was the one that like
threw itself up against the glass and was
like really loud and screaming.
The other gorillas seem a
little bit more peaceful.
Those are the ones that are handsome.
Like you saw that one gorilla
that everyone was freaking
out about in the zoo in
Japan because everyone
thought it was like a good,
it's actually a very good looking
gorilla, but yeah, that was weird.
It a weird here. It was really
weird. You will never find
another gorilla like me.
I, yeah, like sexy gorilla.
That's why they freak me out there.
Just so human like that is just,
it's unsettling to me and I don't like
when they make gorillas have agendas like
that commercial where the little girl is
deaf and she's doing sign language with
the other gorilla. It's like all
very surette orangutan. What? Tam?
My hope that that's the ones that,
look if I was a fucking chimp,
that's what I would look like.
The ones with all the stringy hair,
orange ones look like old men
but they're like sign language in each
other and it's like, oh that's sweet.
Like they're communicating through sign
language and then all of a sudden that
orangutan is like,
oh,
but like the way you live is destroying
my life. And it's like wait a minute.
And it was like for about palm oil or
peanut oil and it was like don't get the
monkey eyeball. Everything just
shocking. Cause now did you see,
I told you this morning I didn't see that.
I get it,
but don't bring the animals into it.
And deaf children,
like I just felt like that was his fucking
monkeys with their agendas. I didn't,
um, I didn't see the clip, but
I just, I just read about it.
Some reporter as Bernie Sanders,
the fact that he's staying in the race,
they asked him if he was
being sexist by staying in it.
Like he couldn't handle
lion two way Hallman.
Why is that sexist for him to
stay in there? A lot of us,
the reporter wants Hillary Clinton.
They want him out. They want him out.
They want Trump out. Even Republicans
like where the money's at. They,
they are gonna except Hilary
Clinton before Trump and before, um,
uh,
Bernie Sanders.
And what I love about Trump and Bernie
Sanders was it showed that enough
Americans are sick of this
standard Republican Democrat.
Like Hillary Clinton is the
standard fucking Democrat.
She's got the same money in our pockets.
The Republican [inaudible] general
Republican candidate would have had any of
those other fucking guys that was running
basically. Um, and it's, you know,
it's just,
that means just the 1% is going to get
more fucking rich and they're going to
push down the middle class,
the same fucking bullshit.
They're going to stay the course.
They don't want somebody that's
off to the side. I got to, uh,
I just had a scary thought. What
was that Trump president? No,
I was thinking about,
I don't know that around its
residents know that orangutan thing.
And I just literally got a picture of an
orangutan like in the way I said Tang,
like the drink my whole life, isn't
it? Orangutan? No, it's a ring. A Tan.
It is. Nobody's said. We don't think
that's true. Well, oh wait, is it
rang a Tan. I just, it was making me think
of planet of the apes where it's like,
oh yeah. Yep. And I got met.
Everybody made fun of what's his face,
just fell and potato with the knee.
I always did potato Po. Tay told,
I think I used to smell,
I mean spell tomato with an e at the end.
Cause the toe. Yeah. It's like
does it toe. So we're both done.
Well that's why we found
each other. That's right.
Cause there was no one to be on
the day going like, oh my God,
this person's an idiot. We were both
gone like, wow, this person gets me.
I'm excited for your birthday tomorrow.
You'll never find Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo.
Yeah you are.
You're very resigned this year.
I've noticed even now talking about it
as much because I'm in the writer's room.
I know what's going to happen.
My birthday.
I'm going to fucking go to the writer's
room and stare at a computer all day.
Yeah.
What if this person says this and then
called back to that story til still
track. But they'll probably
give you a cake at the office.
No, cause there's somebody
whose birthday was yesterday.
That was the oh yeah.
You guys have somebody's first day.
Today's the ninth in mind is
Friday. Yeah. If they get a cake,
if they get me a cake,
it's because they all want cake.
Um, no. I know what I
wanna do for my birthday.
What do you want to do for
your birthday? Um, tell me.
Well,
you know,
in a perfect world my back would be fine
and I'd take you up in the helicopter
with an instructor. Of course, you
know. Oh, that'll be fun. Yeah.
And we'd fly over the ocean and I'd
be singing where no more nurture our
[inaudible]. I would do
that. My name is John Dacre.
I name is John Dacre.
That's my favorite fucking thing ever.
I just doubled more than
any question in the world.
[inaudible] Mori,
what's the first religious
song you sing? So, oh, um,
[inaudible] I like when he's feeling
good. He goes, when he entered his skull,
oh
hey.
Had a fucking meltdown.
She was on TV and he just got in his
fucking head and I don't think he'd ever
been in his head in his life.
I bet he's a really cerebral guy and he
couldn't understand that for the first
time ever. His head, his brain was failing
him. He was really looking around like,
I'm just as confused.
Spot this as you are.
Then he choked and I feel like
in church or wherever it is,
because the woman playing the piano,
she is like,
I guess she gives lessons in that town.
And I,
I'm sure that insurance,
he kills it.
But then he's in that public access
studio. I don't think it kills a camera.
I think he can change his legs.
He just,
he can carry a tune and they bury them
in with like 40 people around them.
Right, right, right. He's
probably still weird.
What kind of car are you think he drives?
It's something very old and something
like tragically unhip Brown,
Brown. He drives a
brown, a brown interior.
Like it's this brown on Brown.
Yeah.
It's like an old Pontiac
Bonneville [inaudible]
then old Napoli.
Oldsmobiles [inaudible]
my name is John Dacre.
My name is John Dacre.
Let them fuck.
There's so much. You guys have
to see this. No, no. I already,
I already talked to him.
I do love it.
We got a table read, so I got to go over
my lines here today. They're Nino. Um,
Bebo. Let me a, I gotta do a little,
some reeds here. All right. Helix.
Helicase I don't know. Uh, your
helix, probably helix. Helix.
Your unique.
You don't walk like anyone else talk like
anyone else or sleep like anyone else.
So why is your mattress one size fits all?
I don't know cause we're all
basically the same height. You know,
unless you're like an NBA freak because
a truly customized mattress will cost
you five to 10 10,000 bucks until now.
Now
my name is John Dacre. Go to
Hu calyx, sleep.com answered.
He looks sleep.com I keep
thinking of the band for a answer,
a few simple questions and they'll run
a three d biochemical model of your body
through the proprietary algorithms
they've developed with the help of the
world's leading ergonomics
and biomechanics.
It's like just to troll me biomechanics
experts as a mistake. You know why?
Because my brain is already going.
All right,
so they take a three d image of your
body and then that's on the Internet
somewhere, right? It's
a custom mattress. Yeah.
But any information goes on the Internet.
People can hack in.
So someone hacks in and see what that,
they take that five 11 now and then they
make some blow up doll of your body and
then someone's fucking a rubber version
of you will here in the Pacific with the
bill birthdays. All again. Yeah. This is,
I have a theory about the internet.
I don't give a fuck what it is.
Somebody's jerking off to
it. I don't care. Yeah.
There's somebody that
gets excited about a,
a kid getting dragged around by his ankle,
by a fucking gorilla.
I used to say that about
the goodwill to like,
you didn't like it because you
just assume that everyone just,
just on that thing,
like all the clothes and all that,
like really cool vintage stuff.
You're like,
I don't want something that
somebody just on. And I'm like,
why do you automatically go
to somebody just on something?
Cause if people are animals,
cause people show go out to
public events in their bare feet.
That's why you want this sweatpants.
You want somebody old couch,
everything's been fucked on or it's just,
that's gross animals. All right,
let's continue with the advertising
helix. Yeah, I doubt the band was
called Helix also, by the way. Yes,
they were. Oh, are you sure? Like
you've heard of like a double helix,
like that's not what they're talking
about. Oh No, it wasn't that deep. Oh,
give me your door. Oh, she, okay.
And what'd you're gonna do?
Rock. They don't remember.
There's deep lyrics back in the 80s.
Helux Helix,
Helix customers report a 30%
improvement in overall sleep quality.
I should really do this with my site.
And for couples,
they customize each side of the mattress.
Ooh, wow. We get along so much better.
Um,
your mattress arrives at your door in
about one week and shipping is 100% free.
That's why everyone from
Gq magazine to Forbes,
they're all talking about helix sleep.
You have 100 nights to try it out.
And if you don't love it,
they'll pick it up for free,
gross and give you 100% refund.
No questions asked.
I want to try to say interest. You're
ruining it for, hey, what is that state?
I thought you said, no
question. My fault. Go to helix.
Sleep TECOM slash. Burn and get
$50 off your order. That's helix.
sleep.com/burr. He likes sleep.com/.
Burn. I'm sure they're great and you know,
I gotta fuck around so people
keep listening. Oh boy.
Here we go. Club. Debbie.
What glove? Debbie club. Debbie w club.
Debbie like Bush clubbed
Jimmy. Okay. I speak Spanish.
Convenience club.
Debby and my dad's down to South America.
Delivers wine straight to
your door. Personalized. Uh,
we send you whan that is
personalized to your palate slash.
Tastes through our pallet quiz,
our recommendations become even more
personalized with every bottle your rate.
See now they already have your body for
the rubber thing right now they know.
Yeah. Now they know what your Palette's
like them and they literally, you know,
what's the next thing of like you
can be, what's your race dude? Um,
unique. Sorry if everybody's
ears there. Sorry.
We work with the top wine makers and
grow up winemakers and grow fro Islam
around the world directly to make
all of our wine I quality and value
$13 dollar bottles would
normally retail for $20. No risk.
You choose type and quality of Bald
Eagles with no membership fee or
cancellation fee and 100%
satisfaction guarantee.
We partner with local artists to develop
wine labels that are unique works of
art right now at club Debbie,
weapons of mass destruction is offering
listeners $20 off your first order when
you go to club. Debbie, don't do that to
them. I never really won the election.
That's dotcom slash bar and it gets even.
I know y'all hate paying.
Why is it blowing out here?
I know you all hate paying for shipping,
so club Debbie should have voted for Jim
will actually pay for your shipping on
orders of four bottles of more,
so some time off your to do list.
Just go to clip Gebbia I never really
did anything.com/ [inaudible] see from my
watch to get $20 off your first order.
Now that's club Debbie
at.com/bar oh when the last one?
No,
our old friend Zip.
But crudely,
are you hiring?
Do you know where to post your
jobs to find the best candidates?
Posting your job at one place is not
enough to find quality candidates.
If you want to find the perfect hire,
you need to post all of your jobs on the
top job sites and now you know you need
to post your job on all the top
job sites and now you can with zip,
but [inaudible] dot com you can post jobs
to 100 plus job sites including social
media networks like Facebook and
Twitter, man, all with a single click.
Find candidates in any city
or industry nationwide.
Just post once and watch all of your
qualified candidates roll into zip
recruiter's. Easy to use interface, no
juggling emails or calls to your office.
Quickly screen candidates,
rate them and hire room right.
How are you to the right person fast?
I like your titties. Come on over.
Find out why zip
recruiter has been used by over
800,000 businesses are right now.
My listeners can try zip
but good for free by going to zip.
Yeah.
[inaudible] dot com slash bird that's zip
recruiter.com/bar there's too
many of these. One more time.
ziprecruiter.com/ [inaudible] all right,
there you go. And that's your podcast.
Just checking in on you.
Please go to all things,
comedy.com to listen to more
podcast and see some fine, friendly,
funny faces and an apology from the
Great Andrew Families last year, uh,
last year, last week, uh, you
accidentally had some repeat material. Um,
he wanted me to apologize on Monday
for that. I forgot to sell his sincere,
his apologies and condolences during
this difficult time for all of you.
Please enjoy this fills up you,
Andrea. Please enjoy this music.
I'm actually going to tell him to play
her became Cox Chameleon A. Wow. Wow. Wow.
God. Put happy pre birthday
baby. Oh, thank you very much.
Happy Birthday to me.
Happy Birthday.
Oh goes happy birthday to you.
You frack old car. All right,
I'll talk to you guys on Monday.
Have a good weekend.
You sons of bitches.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's still the Monday
morning podcast and uh,
same in Raleigh, Durham airport,
which I don't know if it's,
I think they actually have the balls
to call us an international airport.
I'm not sure. I don't think
it's international cause
the lines went that long.
Uh, yeah. That's one of the dumbest
things I've ever fucking said.
Let gets her lash and the
lines went that long. Really?
He didn't see anybody on
a fucking Jeannie rug.
So you don't think that flies
anywhere else? You idiot. All right.
I'm not in a good mood. Why
Bill? Why aren't you in a
good mood? I'll tell you why.
Because, uh, your cousin
in Raleigh, North Carolina,
there's no fucking connected,
no direct flights to Los Angeles.
So for some fucking reason I asked,
Oh God,
the lady with the voice
[inaudible] hang on a second.
Every five seconds. Yes. Okay. All right.
Okay. Correct. Phone message. What? You
don't have a cell phone with friends?
We have that number, right? Unbelievable.
Pick up a courtesy phone.
That's so fucking stupid.
Everybody has cell phones.
Why would you use that archaic
form in an airport? Okay.
Whatever. Uh, anyways. Yeah.
So I'm in Raleigh at, uh,
I want to get to La for some fucking
reason. I have to fly to Cleveland first.
And uh, it's annoying enough when
you have a connecting flight,
but you know,
why can't it be in a city that's at least
going in the direction that I want to
go? I'm going to go fucking
West. I want better.
They're making me fly north a
little bit west. But you know,
at the end of the day, it's fucking north
going north of the Mason Dixon line,
you know, Mason Dixon Line
just to keep, uh, yeah.
What does that leave the ladies
fucking so fucking loud over there.
Why is it, you know, in
society, why can't I just,
why can't you just lean over to her right
now and just be like, hey, Hey lady. Hey.
Yeah you do.
Could you shut the fuck up please?
Or at the very least get you talk a
lot quieter because no one gives a fuck
about whatever the fuck it is
that you're yelling about it much.
You stupid fucking board meeting.
You know what I mean?
Who the fuck are you talking
to? It's fucking, I guess
it's 10 25 in the morning.
You know what's annoying me as she's
talking really loud and her eyebrows or
it's full fucking mast. Uh, Jesus.
Is there anybody even listened
to these announcements? How?
Look at this person coming,
buddy. She's got the, uh,
the p diddy syndrome or
the Shaquille O'neal Syndrome.
You know those, you know those
people. Uh, okay. As on a Cosby shirt.
You know those people who fucking,
their mouths are open even
when they're not talking.
Can I call that P diddy syndrome?
Is that what you call a bill? Yeah,
that is what I call it.
All right.
I have a flask of time on
Rpm that I'm going to be,
I'm going to be taking, but I can't take
it because I have a connecting flight,
so I'm going to stay awake till
I get to Cleveland. By the way,
my flight to Cleveland is delayed,
you know, they said because of wind,
you know what I mean? Really rough wind,
which I don't really understand. You know,
it's like, isn't that how the
fucking plane gets off the ground?
You wait for Augusta wind and your drive
into it. You know? I mean, granted,
I never took a physics class.
I was getting you.
I don't even know how to fucking
plane gets off the ground,
which is one of the reasons why I
have such a fear of flying pick of,
I actually understood it.
If anybody listening to this could
actually explain in layman's terms how a
fucking 10 ton piece of metal
with a bunch of people and various forms
of physical condition condition can get
off the goddamn ground, actually
get out, gets off the ground.
I just don't understand how
it stays off the ground.
Like I can get off the ground, I
can take a running leap, you know,
and for good 0.8 seconds,
I am actually airborne,
but I quickly come crashing down to
the ground and roll my fucking ankle.
You know, it's kind of like a boat to
how the fuck does a boat that sank.
You know what I mean?
Dave,
he just displaced the weight
across the water and spill.
I don't, I don't, you know,
then a bunch of people get on
and then it still doesn't sink.
It just goes down into the water
a little bit more. All right.
I think we've established that Jesus
Christ will on this guy is dressed,
he's got some guy he looks
like he should be yodeling.
He has on khaki shorts that about five
inches above his knee from sort of brown,
low cut suede hiking shoes
with ankle below the ankle.
Black socks. He just needs like, I
think, what do you call it? A shaft.
One of those sticks with the,
with the curl on it.
Jesus Christ.
He's probably going to a whore house
and this looks like he has some sort of
twisted fetish. I wonder what's in
that briefcase. He's drinking coffee,
but he's trying to appear
normal. Um, anyways,
if you're a new to this page, uh,
this is the Monday morning podcast.
I do one of these every single week.
I hype upcoming gigs.
I rant about both ships and people send
me questions and I tried to answer to
the best of my ability.
And uh,
yeah,
that's about it.
And I gotta admit my computer is tucked
away in my bag and I don't know what the
fuck the questions off for the second,
second week in a row.
You know what it is? I have one of the,
I have one of those g four Max. I met my,
uh, laptop was about four years old
and uh, actually have legs on it,
like an old TV and a in an
antenna fucking older, right.
And the battery Evidentaly
is defective. So, uh,
when I turned it on, it loses battery
power about nine seconds. Actually.
We'll say I have 75% battery
power and then it says, um, um,
two seconds. I don't know what the
fuck I'm talking about. All right,
let's just get to the shit I
have coming up in my career.
I had stand up on the guys' choice awards,
uh,
for Spike TV and that is going to be a,
it's going to be airing on June
22nd Sunday night on Spike TV.
Uh, it's actually a pretty big award
show. I was very amazed at the, a
level of a celebrity that was there.
It's like Harrison Ford.
Cameron is Jeremy Pivot, you know
what I mean? Spike TV, no offense.
But I thought it was going to be like
Lee majors and Micky Dolenz and me,
you know, that's what I thought I was
going to be. And then I showed up.
I was like, Holy Shit. You know that Steve
Carell's? Yes, it is. Isn't that amazing?
And uh, I was not sitting
seated at his table. I was uh,
I was seated at a table.
I don't know what the fuck one guy was,
a reality show director. And the rest of
them were a seat filling horse. I think.
Um, at least that's what it said
on there. Uh, the name tag. Um,
so anyways, all right, let's get
to the podcast questions that, uh,
that I can remember. Uh,
buck with the announcement.
Can you maintain she please
fucking airports they make you hate.
I mean,
Goddamn flight is delayed.
I'm actually looking, uh,
first horrific thought I had at a day.
I have the USA Today paper
in front of me. And, uh,
one of the pictures they have as of,
uh,
this guy looks like he's in the bowling
Joey. I can describe them all right?
He's got a checkered shirt on with
a t shirt underneath it. And, uh,
he's about up to his man tits and water
hanging onto a rubber raft that has
some,
a coastguard looking guy in it.
He's basically too fat to
get in the fucking boat. Um,
and he's walking along and it said Midwest
storm turns deadly and says a seven
reported dead at the tornadoes and heavy
rain pound states in the heartland.
So I'm like, wow, that's, you know,
at least I'm not fucking up to
my man tits and a rain water,
you know, it's probably eels and
fucking water moccasins and shit.
But then there's a part of me because
there's so many goddamn people is a kind
of happy, you know, wash away a few,
like the traffic go down a little bit.
There's not a fucking terrible thought,
but I actually,
I actually think that shit
underneath that it says a
FDA's tomato warnings grow.
This is all the happy
news I've looked at today.
Outbreak of Salmonella from raw tomatoes
spreads to 16 states with up to 150
people reported ill.
You know,
now a lot of people would look
at that like that's a bad thing.
But I look at it like,
look,
those 150 people fucking die from eating
tomatoes or at the very least get some
horrific cases of diarrhea where
they're not going to get into a car. Uh,
you know, the roads would be a
little bit clearer. You know,
somebody, I guess, uh, this
is the only happy news.
They don't have one fucking happy thing
on the front page. What do we got here?
US gas average $4 and rising and then
they have a cartoon picture of a hand
squeezing a house with money
falling out of the bottom.
You know what the funny thing is is if
they didn't even bring this shit up,
I wouldn't even know it was happening.
Who would know that housing
houses were fucking, uh,
the values dropping? How would you even
know that if they didn't bring it up?
Why don't they just stopped talking about
it and we're all walking around like
happy idiots will continue to spend
our money in malls and there won't be a
recession.
You know what,
that might be the second
dumbest thing I've ever said.
You know something I really resent the
way fucking pilots got to dress like they
were on the love boat. You
know what I mean? What is this?
What is an awful fucking uniform?
Now?
Of course he's going to sit next
to me so I can't make fun of them.
You know what I mean? I
hate like the, the, the,
the shoulder pads with the stripes
on them, you know what I mean?
If they just came back from
battle as opposed to a round
trip to fucking Seattle,
you know what I mean? I don't
know. As a shops at target,
it's going to go shiny golf shirts
on and those Seinfeld white sneakers,
you know what? There isn't one well
dressed person in Raleigh, Durham airport.
I keep thinking everybody has on a Cosby
show, but it's the same fucking guy.
He just keeps pacing back and forth.
So every time, you know, I look up,
he's on my right and then I
look, looked down, I looked up,
he's on my left and I think it's a
different guy ladies. Definitely a mother.
You here with the little
personal size pizza,
mothering hips swinging to and fro
guys a psycho.
Look at him,
get a backpack.
Probably tried to hike the Appalachian
trail. Get fucking Ricketts.
Umm. All right. So, uh, yeah,
the fuck was I talking about?
My girlfriend wants to see Kung Fu panda.
That's what I have to look forward to when
I get back to la. She wants to see it.
God damn cartoon about
some fucking martial arts.
Why would a fucking pants, I need to
learn Kung Fu. You know what I mean?
Why would I need how to throw kicks when
everybody knows that a bear naturally
just has that like you.
Have you ever seen like a watch
discovery channel and show up?
They're killing like a, uh, I don't
know. Fucking Yak, whatever. What,
what the fuck did they
kill an elk or deer?
They don't come up and grab it by
the throat. All right. All messy.
Like all those other creditors, they have
the bears come up. They have like that,
that fucking, how do you describe
it? Got fucking bionic bitch slap.
You know what I mean? Just
Bam. Just breaks their neck.
So right there,
that's the grizzly bear fruit.
The equivalent of the one inch punch.
Will you stop yelling?
I think she kind of heard me on that.
She's literally looking at me screaming.
Can you hear a voice?
She one of those fucking women.
I hate women who are like 40 years
old and they talk like they ate
probably like guys killer wise. So
while they just get sick of their voice,
this guy, what a stupid fucking thing to
say. You know what? This is the bills.
A more on podcast today.
I'm just in a bad fucking mood.
Fucking plane was supposed to take off
at 10 1510 45 I got some 40 year old lady
with a kid's voice screaming and then I
got the the pie. Oh fuck my plane's here.
That, you know, it's funny,
the plane that I'm flying from
Raleigh Durham International Airport,
Esquire is uh,
actually looks like the kind of plane
that Tom Cruise flies crying himself.
You know, I was getting excited when I
see those, cause I imagine that, you know,
I'm a fucking rock star and I'm getting
on it by myself as opposed to the fact
that I'm getting onto it with 40 other
people. This is how fucked up Raleigh,
North Carolina is as far as a,
uh,
airport goes the plane.
I actually flew down here from New
York City and I flew down here on a, a,
a plane that had propellers.
I'm not even lying to you,
but it was a new plane and I was
like, wow, they still going with this.
You know what I mean?
And it was one of those deals,
there was so few people on the flight
that I was sitting in like feet five a and
they go, sorry, excuse
me, excuse me there.
And I'm like, bitch, fucking bitch. What?
Excuse me, bitch. And she's like, sir,
I don't need to listen. Okay. I didn't
say that. That's what I was thinking.
I just said, I said, uh, I said yes,
but the underlying, the way
I said it was like, what?
And she's like,
I need you to move to the back of the
plane so we can redistribute the weight.
You know what I mean?
And it's like, really?
You're basically telling me if I
don't go to the back of this plane,
that it's gonna like what fucking tip
over when we go, when we go to take off.
I think that makes me feel as a
customer, you know what I mean?
But you know, they don't give
a shit fucking hilarious.
She makes me move back, but she
sits up front, you know what I mean?
And when that stupid little fold
down stewardess chair, it's like,
why don't you sit in the
back? I'm a customer. Okay,
I want to stay here. And this lady
dressed like my fourth grade teacher.
Wow.
Black on black suit with Bruce Lee
Kung Fu shoes and a shiny pink blouse
underneath it. I don't know if she's
dressed like my fourth grade teacher.
When Nancy Reagan one or the other hand.
She did.
He's dressed like a
first lady. Uh, fuck me.
All right. Wow. Ooh, let's
get with these fucking, oh,
you guys in the planes.
That's why he's shirts so bright.
So I assured so Brighton,
his mustache is so short.
That girl does not trim her Bush.
You can just tell. Just tell.
She's going all natural.
I don't know what it is about her.
That lady there has an above ground
swimming pool and her hug. Yeah,
look at that shoulder tattoo.
I fucking nailed it. I know it.
Above ground swimming pool
made stuffed crust pizza
guy there was good at basketball
because he's in shape.
He's black and he has
dreadlocks right there,
which means he's like the sixth man.
You haven't noticed that.
The black dudes with the dreadlocks, they
like rebound guy. You know what I mean?
There's never been a Michael Jordan
style player with dreadlocks.
You got dreadlocks and you
play in the NBA. You, uh,
you get like fucking 12
rebounds a game and uh,
you can knock out 12 old ladies with
your fucking elbow. I don't know what.
All right. I ran out of
references there. Wow.
Pre Pant Khakis of pretense.
There you go. You're married.
There's no reason to give a fuck anymore.
Why would you dress like that?
Look at this black guy. Hey. Go. Huh? He's
still going with the extra baggy shit.
Wow. That look was like
10 ago. Remember that one?
Fuck guys would go to footlocker and
they would find those a quadruple fucking
XLT shirts even though
they were five foot six.
I always thought they look
like a, you know, like at the,
a bang of broad over
there in the next morning.
Now she gets up and put some
money, a tee shirts. Um,
all right. I'm just making fun of
people. Not because I'm like, well,
I am kind of a concept,
but I'm just making fun of me because I
don't have my podcast questions in front
of me. So, uh,
why don't we hide some upcoming gigs
and lady looks like Robert Plant from
behind. Oh, it's the same fucking lady.
She's got all kinds of lists going on.
What happened to Robert
Plant? Man, Jesus Christ,
that kind of a great write up to age 46
and all of a sudden now he looks like he
should be in like a children's
book. Like, like one of those, uh,
like a troll. I don't know. What about
a fairy tale? That's what it looks like.
Robert Plant looks like. He looks like
he's in a fairytale. You know what I mean?
Is this is,
this is a cruel thing about life
is even if you stay in shape,
life is still going to make you
look awful because for some reason,
even if you stay at your high
school, wait, you fucking
head never stops growing.
So if you don't get a little out of shape,
if you look fucking ridiculous,
you look like a,
I just lost my train of thought.
The finest stuff taking this
time on a PM. No, you're not.
You look like if you've
seen that fucking guy. Uh,
he's like 45 years old and he shredded,
I might've talked about this last
week again with the Mike Epps had um,
you know, the guy late, late at night,
he does all the physical fitness shit.
He's like 46 year old
years old and he shredded,
but for some reason he still looks weird
and it's his head because his head,
I know it's not the head,
it's your fucking knows it's
your ears or something like that.
Something about your head.
It just keeps getting bigger.
Like classic example is Ted Kennedy.
Okay.
Ted Kennedy has been in the news lately,
has got a fucking brain
tumor or something. Right.
If you will get that guy's
head in the sixties Brandon,
all those Kennedy's had big heads.
You know what I mean?
It's one of the reasons why two of
them got, got, got assassinated.
It's like there was no way to miss.
That's just fucking me. It really is.
But I got to tell you something, man.
I saw Ted Kennedy,
I shook his hand one time and his head
is as big as the seat that I'm sitting
and he has been the biggest fucking
head I've ever like. It wasn't, it was,
I believe I was just staring at it.
I couldn't fuck and I got a big hit,
but this guy's fucking hap
was pretty huge. And uh,
you probably want to, how did
I meet him? I actually, uh,
I fucking shook his hand and Bill
Clinton's hand, the long fucking story.
Just remind me,
I'll tell it to you next week.
Let's stay on track you with how big his
fucking head is. I just kept looking.
I just could not believe the size of like,
I just want it to like,
ah, I wish there was a way to just like
hold his head just to see how much it
weighed. You know, I, I'm not even joking.
I bet his head ways, like, like 27 pounds,
27 fucking pounds. When you think about
that, you know who out there lift weights,
you know that when you're doing your
warmup set and he grabbed like, yeah,
well let's, let's go with 35
to 35 pound plates. You know,
plan you can do with one hand.
You know what they should have.
They should have like part of
the strong man competition.
Instead of those little
kettle balls there,
they should have like little Kennedy
hats and each one of them gets a,
it's a stupid idea, you know, that's
why I don't have a fucking show on TV.
All right, let, let's, let's get to
skip the hype in the upcoming gigs. Um,
first of all, I just was in Raleigh, North
Carolina at a good night's comedy club.
I want to thank everybody who came out
to the shows. I had a great time and, uh,
I got drunk every night down at the bar
downstairs and I watch myself x go up
two games to none and a,
I'm not gonna lie to you.
I didn't know watch one selfie game
all year. I fucking hate pro hoop
fro who is the worst. Like,
it's just too goddamn long.
You Watch college basketball,
it's exciting. The crowd's
into it and it's over.
It seems like it's over in an hour
pro hoop with,
with the fucking files and the timeouts.
And I mean that final five minutes,
final five minutes, it takes like
45 minutes to play to the point.
You don't even give a shit anymore.
But I'm a little test to Phil
Jackson for bitching about the files.
You know what I mean? Fucking baby. I
can tell you right now, if you gamble,
would definitely bet on the Lakers.
Definitely done on the Lakers on game
three because they are going to call 9,000
files on the fucking Celtics because
Phil Jackson's a fucking baby.
You know what I mean? Give
me a goddamn break. Well,
what about that guy in the Lakers
who stop dribbling at half court,
ran the west rest of the way and dunk
the ball and they didn't call traveling.
What about that? Okay, you're getting
calls too. I don't want to hear it.
Um, and also that two, three,
two playoff system is bullshit.
You know what I mean?
You give home court advantage to the
fucking visitor through game five.
They keep saying the Celtics
have home court. They don't.
The next three games are in la. We get
to spend a fucking weak out there, man.
Have you maintain chain please with the
person who wears their current next to
the deal jail please report to the
fucking front office. All right.
I'm starting to talk way too
loud with Tourette's. Um,
I dunno man. I thought the Lakers were
going to beat us and like six games.
I thought they were going to crush us.
I'm really impressed.
Ray Allen keeps hitting his shots.
Uh,
we're just going to have to weather the
storm. I think Colby is going to get 30,
40 every game and if we can just somehow
weather that storm, uh, I dunno.
I still think it's going
seven games and uh, I dunno,
it's gun. It's going to be
great. It's going to be great.
I just don't watch ESPN anymore.
Fucking jackets. So overhype everything.
Look at this lady,
Jesus Christ.
She's never committed a crime
in their life and gay. My taxis,
I go to church every week. I
have a little tote bag like, hey,
and I packed the exact
perfect amount of clothes.
I don't swallow. I'm a man. I'm
getting crude on these podcasts.
I got to stop with this. Okay. All
right, well that was a good 25 minutes.
There you go. Visit, visit.
Good damn near half hour of us silliness
to get your week started off right. Oh,
Paul, you guys have a, uh,
have a great week and uh,
you know something, you know,
just, just be happy. You don't
travel for a living. And Andy,
if you travel for a living,
you know my condolences because
this shit is ridiculous. Um,
but anyways, upcoming gigs,
uh, like I said, Spike TV,
the guy's choice awards,
uh, June 20 seconds.
First Time I ever did award show and uh,
I killed on it.
Hopefully a,
it will come across that way on TV.
You never know what
happens in post production,
but I was really excited to do that.
And uh,
I'm going to be at the
punchline in Atlanta on Jesus
Christ as testimony memory.
I think it's June 19th through the 21st.
The date should be right there. Uh,
what else do I got?
I got Pittsburgh coming up and uh,
fuck what else do I have the
Improv in Miami in August.
That's all I can really remember for
the summer because I'm getting old.
Speaking of which my 40th birthday is
tomorrow and uh oh well the love of right
with the person who let the fat slug.
We have a bag of button down near the,
the conquests.
Oh is this me? This is me. Okay.
The board and my slight thanks for hanging
out with me is I waited for my, uh,
my trip back to La via Cleveland
flying to fucking Cleveland.
I just wish, uh, I dunno.
I wish I wasn't going to Cleveland.
All right, that's it. Um,
please keep the podcast questions coming.
I'm going to do,
I'm going to answer like 9 million podcast
questions next week cause I do have
all of them in my fucking,
my old ass left.
My laptop is made out of wood. Thank you.
That's how fucking old it is. All right,
I'm getting on the plane. I'm
going to take some more. No,
I can't take Tylenol pm cause I'll sleep
through my fucking connecting flights
and I'm going to take it after I get
a, after I get on the, uh, like, oh,
you want to get something
fucking hilarious?
I called my dad yesterday and I wished
him a happy father's day. And he's like,
son, I love you to death, but it's
next Sunday. He had dumped, fuck.
So and then he wished me a happy birthday
for tomorrow. And I was like, yeah,
well my birthday's on Tuesday. That's
where I get it. You're all dumb. Fuck.
And that's our relationship and
that acute family little story.
All right, I'm gonna leave access
me and 90 other people here,
so I'm going to get on this
fucking 40 saying okay. All right.
That's it. Thanks for listening. Uh,
please keep the questions coming and
please somebody explain to me how a boat
floats and how plants.
All right.
Thank you.
[inaudible] tell you this story.
I'm flying solo show,
um,
and always working with Nick Kroll.
You're guaranteed you're going to
laugh your ass off. I'll fucking deck.
Can I kiss? The kids asked and I
fucking love him. I think he's,
I think he's a fucking
genius. So anyways, um,
I go, I go to the airport
and I'm taking the red eye,
taking this 10 55 flight, nine fucking
stop. Cause that's how I do it.
All right.
I'm on a good plane.
Why would I want to get off it and switch
and roll the dice and get on another
one? You know, let's
just fucking get there.
When, when I drive up to San Francisco,
I don't pull over and fucking, uh,
Burbank and then get hit new, another
cup. We get it bill. All right.
Yeah.
So I get on the fucking
plane, right? I use my miles,
bumped myself up like a fancy
person, you know, maybe,
maybe I invented that cheesecake factory.
People are thinking and then they
see how I'm dressed and I go, oh no,
he didn't vent the cheesecake factory.
Um,
and I go to go to sit down on my
seat and I go to set my bag down.
I was going to set it
down right in front of me.
And the nice fellow sit next to me,
he goes,
why don't you stick it in
the middle of this room?
And he moved his bag out of
the way. I'm like, all right,
this guy's a solid dude or whatever.
And then all of a sudden the waitress by
a stewardess, whatever, she comes by, um,
flight attendant, whatever the
fuck you supposed to call him,
she comes up and she's, uh, can I get
you [inaudible] to Drake? And I was like,
yeah, can I get out? Let me get a
water please. Ice or no ice. What?
However you make it.
Stop acting like it's a fucking
Martini. It's war, right?
Just give me a water
with ice. Thank you. Um,
and the, the guy next to me, he orders
the doers. Neat. No Irish, no nothing.
Just put it in there. So they bring our
drinks. All right. And I'm really thirsty.
So I start sucking mind down and
he just throws his back. Like,
it's nothing like fucking John Wayne
right before he's going to turn around and
beat up three guys, three
mustachioed guys in the 1930s. Right?
So, um, I'm just sitting
there and everybody's getting
on the flight, you know,
when I'm looking around at the passengers,
you know,
fucking doing whatever I'm doing and
all of a sudden the guy next to me,
Mr Doers, goes to me, uh, he goes, excuse
me? He goes, are you afraid to fly?
And I looked at him, I was like,
what? He goes, are you afraid to fly?
And I go, no, no, I'm
not. And he goes, he goes,
all right, but you know, it's,
he goes, it's okay. You know,
if it's okay to tell me
if you're afraid to fly,
okay.
And it's immediately getting weird. And
I'm like, no, I'm not afraid to fly.
And, and I'm thinking in my
head, wait, is he afraid to fly?
And that's why he's drinking
the way he just drank.
And now he's hoping that I'm going
to be afraid to fly. So he, you know,
he just wants to open up. That's what
I'm thinking. And I'm like, yeah,
no, I'm not afraid to fly. And
he won't leave it alone. He goes,
all right, cause you know,
you're, you're, you're fidgeting,
you're looking around at other passengers.
And I'm sitting there looking at it like,
is this guy fucking serious? And I go,
no. I go, I'm not afraid to fly.
So now I'm like, fuck this guy.
I'm not talking scaffold rest of flight.
This guy's weird, man. It's like 30,
just get painted pictures like
32 year old. Why are in shape?
But like, why are we white? Dude,
he's got a skully cap on
with fucking glasses. Um,
you know,
and uh,
he goes,
uh,
like there's like a minute of silence
and people still getting on the plane.
And then he goes, hey, sorry
about that. So we, we just,
we just got off on the wrong foot. He's
like, my name's so and so. He goes,
what's your name? And then I'm thinking
in my head like, what's my name?
My name's frank.
I wanted to give them like a f by just
some reason I just wanted it's bill.
And he goes, oh, hey, bill.
And he goes, nice to meet you.
So we shake hands and I'm just looking at,
I don't have any poker face.
I'm looking at the guy like,
what the fuck is your problem?
I'm not even trying to,
not my trying to be pleasant.
I'm already done with this guy. So then
the guy goes, oh hey bill. He goes,
why are you going to Indianapolis Bill?
Right?
Like he's fucking interrogating me and I,
I'm like,
is this guy fucking serious? And I
start doing the math in my head going,
when is this guy like an air marshal? It's
something. And I'm like, no, he's not.
He's fucking slamming bows over here.
Fuck this guy.
So I just go, I go, look, I don't, I
don't have to answer your questions.
Let's sit. And I just looked
straight forward. He goes, okay,
now I'm concerned. Okay, I am concerned.
And I'm looking at him like concerned
about what he goes, you're fidgeting your,
you, you, you have issues with other
passengers and blah blah, blah, blah.
He sucks Peyton like, like this. Like
he's been, I don't know what the fuck,
like psychologically breaking me down.
All right, so now at this, by this point,
they've closed the fucking the door to
the fields collage and we're starting to
taxi.
And I just finally looked at the guy,
uh, ag and I go, I go, you know,
I came up with the FY one point.
I literally stick my hand out cause he
kept saying I was nervous and I stick my
hand right in front of his
face and I hold it level. Oh,
that's what I did the first time. Yeah. I
hold it level. I'll go, I'm not nervous.
And he goes, well, anybody can do that.
And that's when I was like, fuck this guy.
I'm not talking to the guy. Sorry.
Fuck this story up there. And then he,
then he came back, got my name, now he's
going, why are you going to Indianapolis?
And I find looking at him, I say,
listen pal, I'm drinking waters.
You're drinking doers. Okay, there's
no issue over here. And then he goes,
it wasn't doers. What she gave me
wasn't doers really. What was it?
Some sort of spy juice,
you fucking jerk off this point.
I want to punch him right through his
fucking stupid wirey glasses, right?
So he's going like,
you look around hostels and I said
something that just ticked him off.
I was just, yeah, that dude. I go, I don't
have to answer your questions. All right,
leave me alone. And then he
goes, uh, he goes to, he goes,
he starts going like, okay,
now I am really concerned right now. He
goes, why are you going to Indianapolis?
And I just looked at him,
you know, when I start doing,
I start doing like this Ryan Gosling,
you know that little smirk that fucking
Mona Lisa smile he has is he smirks his
way through all this fucking movies.
I do go. I go full on Ryan Gosling.
Now I'm not talking to this guy and I
just keep looking at him and I gave him
that little half of smirk and I just
shake my head. That's my game now.
That's,
this is Mike.
It's like if you're going to be a Dick
Right now with your fucking delusional
authority, right? That
you're going to like,
we're in fucking Guantanamo
and you're gonna waterboard
me, Huh? There's no water,
there's no board.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Here's my smart and I'm just going to
shake my head at you like you're a fucking
pathetic human being. This is what I'm
doing, right? And this is the funny thing.
I'm such a Dick. All they have to
say to the guys, I'm a comedian,
I'm going to do a sold out show there
and that would make them back off,
but I'm a dick. I'm like, fuck this
guy. I want to see what this is going.
So now he's all fucking amped
up and he starts droppingF ,
you know she's saying the f word. He
sitting there going funeral. He goes,
if you don't fucking answer my question
right fucking now I'm going to hit that
call button was sitting there,
taxi and down a fucking getting in line.
I'm going to fucking hit this fucking
button if you blah blah, blah, blah, blah.
And I'm just fucking Mona Lisa smile
going to shake in my head like you are a
fucking retard, right? So now he
sees saying the f word so much.
The lady who's sitting in
front of me diagonally in
front, right in front of him,
turns around and looks at us, and
now my heart's racing. I'm like,
where's this going?
This is going to be great.
I am a hundred percent fucking innocent.
This guy's drunk and I think he's
going to hit that button. Oh,
I got a feeling he's going to hit that
button. What's going to happen? Right?
I want to see what the pilot looks like.
Let's see what the fuck this is going.
Right? So he goes, if you
don't fuck you, he starts,
he starts bringing his heading
up to the button going,
I'm going to hit that button.
You don't think I'll fucking do it.
I'll hit that button and I'm sitting there
smirking and I'm thinking in my head,
go ahead and hit the fucking button.
Let's see what happens.
Let's see what happens. Right? So finally,
now he wants to hit the button
and he can't fucking find it,
and it's an in defense of him. I couldn't
find it either. I was looking up there,
I half wanted to hit it myself.
Then he finally,
he finally finds it and he hits it right?
And now I'm just like,
Holy Shit, what's going to happen? And
he's sitting there going, yeah, Huh,
you want to fucking play this game?
How you want to fucking play this game?
And I'm surprised.
I mean it took like fucking like 30
seconds before a flight attendant,
the one who gave him the booze,
whichever gently wasn't boozed comes over.
And at this point we're like doing
that shit where we're behind the plane,
we're almost ready to take off,
like we're pulling up and
then stop and pull it up.
Then stopping as planes are
taking off. So she goes, yeah,
what's the problem over
here? And he goes, ah,
I'm not comfortable to fly with
this guy. This guy, he's fidgeting,
he's looking around at other fucking
people, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
He's doing all this thing right.
And then the stewardess looks at me and
I'm just sitting there and fucking my
little smart,
just shaking my head.
And I just looking at this
dude just shaking my head like,
this guy's out of his fucking mind.
I don't say a word.
And this guy goes on and on and on about
his fucking psycho babble about how I'm
the security risk.
So she goes to,
so she goes, okay. Um,
any other passengers?
Have you noticed anything? She talked
to everybody first class at this,
is anybody notice anything
odd about this guy?
And The lady who was sitting right in
front of the dude diagonally from me turns
around, she goes, yeah, I've been
listening to this guy brewery, right?
Berating this other passenger.
She's on my side and I haven't
said a fucking word. This is great.
And I'm just sitting there smirking.
Then they'll let the students look to
me and I shrugged my shoulders like,
I don't know what to tell
you. So finally she said, sir,
did you have anything to add
to this? And I just said, look,
I'm just a guy trying to go to
Indianapolis. This guy over here.
He started slamming his doors. I kind
of felt like a rat when I said that.
I go slamming his doors. Next thing you
know, he's dropping the F bomb to me.
Then I'm thinking, oh fuck.
I just said bomb. Right?
Fortunately nothing happened.
So now another fucking the male stewardess
comes over right now. He's going like,
what's going on?
And the captain of the fucking now at
this point we pulled over in the plane has
stopped.
Do you want a 50 people trying to get
to Indianapolis and jerk off over here?
Can't hold his fucking alcohol. Who
just watched a person of interest every,
every, I guess evidently I have no
fucking idea. Now the plane is stopped,
is fucking jerk off,
has stopped the plane
interrogating a Goddamn comedian.
Like I'm in the fucking Taliban and
like he works for the CIA, right?
So now we're just sitting
in the captain is up front in the plane
like saying to the stewards is going
basically relaying, do I really
have to fucking come back there?
This is the last flight of the night.
Is there really a God damn problem.
And that was the vibe when they finally
said to the dose, sit next to me,
are you going to be okay to fly with him?
And at that point it appeased his fucking
ego that he was somehow in control.
And he goes like, you know what? Okay,
it's fine. It's fine. It'll be fine.
It'll be fine.
Yeah.
So they go,
okay.
So now the plane's going again and now
we're now we fucking come around and he's
sitting there fucking,
he's in my ear.
And at this point I am lab like to fucking
laugh. You hear me doing the podcast?
That's what I'm doing. And
he's sitting there going, I,
he goes, you don't, I'm glad.
I'm glad you, I hope you fucking do.
I hope you fucking try something.
I'll be fucking try
something one up there.
I really hope you fucking try something.
And I'm just fucking like God.
Boston laughing, shaking me like, what
are you going to fucking do to me?
What are you going to do to me?
How are you gonna Punch me in the face?
You fucking wirey jackass,
but your fucking glasses on,
you know,
that's a federal offense.
You're going to go to jail if you do
that or something. I Dunno what, right.
So I'm just sitting there fucking
laughing at the guy going, I actually,
at one point I put my fucking little
eye pillow thing on. Do you know,
like I'm going to sleep. Oh, I
had that out too in the store.
This was talking to me. I was like
putting it on is this total mind fuck.
Like I don't know what this guy is.
I'm just trying to go to Indianapolis.
I'm going to sleep. And um, so I got,
I got my fucking eye thing on, right
as he's sitting there threatening me.
Just I was going with total passive
aggressive. It's like, dude,
I'm so not concerned with
you. I'm literally putting
a blindfold on. All right,
so this fucking guy, like
he starts going, he goes,
yeah. He goes, you think
you're fucking one this dude,
he fucking won this. He goes,
Mike, you know my dad is my
dad. He started saying his dads,
some major CEO in Indianapolis.
Doesn't sound like a fucking made story.
I swear to God, this is
all true. He Goes, Mike,
my dad is a major CEO in Indianapolis
and I'll have you fucking arrested.
And The lady turns around again,
I'll have you fucking arrested
the second we get on the ground,
I'm thinking like, for what?
For what? Sitting here,
you fucking loser. Learn how
to hold your alcohol. Right.
And he starts describing the view that
I'm going to have when I go to jail,
like some fucking law and order episode.
Oh you're gonna love it.
You'd be able to see Lucas oil
field and bad, the bad blah blah.
And I'm just sitting here cracking up
laughing and then there's this pause,
right? And I'm thinking finally he finally
shut the fuck up. It's like a three,
four minute pause. He finally just gave
up because I wasn't giving them anything.
I was just laughing and shaking my head.
I was being a dick to them.
I was cause I was enjoying it.
And then there was like a three minute
pause and then all of a sudden he just
goes,
why are you going to Indianapolis Bill.
Yeah.
So we're like 20 minutes into the flight
and am I going to be honest, he's,
my adrenaline was so
going during all of that
because I knew I didn't do anything wrong,
but I thought we were literally going
to go back and there was going to be
fucking cops there. And
they'd be like, if, if, if,
if the fucking stewardess or the pilot
asked me who I am and where I'm going,
I'm going to tell them I respect your
authority. You're just some, Gee, I don't,
you don't have any fucking authority.
I don't have to answer your questions.
It was pro was one of the most
fun experiences I've ever
had with another human being.
Like when somebody thinks that they
have power and you know, they don't,
and all they can do is try just keep
bluffing and raising their voice and start
cursing at you.
And if you just start laughing at them,
the look on their face
is fucking priceless. So
the last thing he said, he said, why are
you going to Indianapolis Bill? Right.
And I fucking started howling,
just fucking holding my stomach,
shaking my head
and with my fucking eye
pillow thing on right.
And I know I'm going to get a ton of
shit that I wear one of those eye,
they're fucking underrated.
Get the one at Brookstone where it's
literally a pillow. I'm telling you,
you can fall asleep 12 noon
facing the sun. It's awesome.
So anyways, like after he,
he asked me what, what,
you know where you're going bill?
You're like, there was like a 10 minute,
like probably 10 minutes had gone by and
I can't fucking sleep because it's so
fun. And to me I can't wait to tell
the story to every comic. I know.
I can't wait to try it on stage to
see if it's funny or whatever. Uh,
so finally I just like got fuck it.
Maybe I'll just get on my computer and I
bring up my eye pillow and I like,
I got to look at the guy cause I know
he's fucking staring at me waiting for me
to do something right.
So I lifted up,
I get my Mona Lisa smile going and I look
over at the guy and dude he is fucking
passed out.
He looked like he got shot.
He was sitting there like his head was
just hanging straight down and anytime
the plane move like his head was Amy,
he little at you got knocked out and
for the rest of the fucking flight all
fucking uh oh. What's Matt
Damon's character? Jack Ryan.
Hold fucking Jack Ryan over here is just,
you know the sky marshal,
the fucking bows bag and God
knows what else he was on.
He was just completely out passed out
for the rest of the fucking flight.
And this is why I'm want to Dick. I am.
I was having so much fun with this guy.
I start,
I can't sleep.
So I start slamming waters because I
want to have to get up and take a piss.
Just to see if this guy's going to
freak out because this security risk is
getting up. And there's,
the joke was on me,
he never regained consciousness and
then I really had to take a Piss,
but I'm such a stubborn fuck.
I was holding it because I wanted to
make sure he was awake when I got up,
cause that was going to give him a little
smirk and then I was going to get out
to sea at the call button
again. Um, but he didn't,
he didn't wake up till we
hit the ground. And um, yeah.
And it's funny. Then he woke up
and it was like four hours later,
so now he'd kind of slept off,
whatever the fuck this guy was on.
And I'm sitting there SmartQ and wait for
the guy who start talking and he won't
look at me and I,
and I think at that point
he kind of fucking realizes
that maybe he got a little
, uh, a little extra little too patriotic.
So we stop.
We stopped at the gate and
everything and we're going to get up.
So I grabbed my shit.
I get up and I'm just kinda looking
at him and he won't look at me.
And then the lady who was
sitting in front of me,
I had this big smile on her face.
She goes, how are you? She goes,
how are you doing? I don't
want good. I go, there I go.
That was an interesting one.
And I said it really loud.
So the guy heard and
didn't say anything and to,
this is what he did to try to save face.
His pillow was kind of stuck behind this
kind of stuck behind his shoulder and
like a weird place.
So he was frustrated with it.
So he ripped it out from behind him
and kind of threw it down on the floor.
Went like,
tried to do some caveman grunt to try
to still have some sort of, yeah. Uh,
I don't know what, so, so that was
my flight to Indianapolis people.
Um, you don't want how, how far into the
fucking podcast are we? That was a long,
that was a long fucking story.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
okay.
[inaudible]
I
will.
Okay.
[inaudible] okay.